depuis une semaine le ministre fédéral
de l'environnement steven guilbeault
doit défendre sa décision d'approuver le
projet pétrolier baie du nord à
terre-neuve-et-labrador ce projet
ajoutera deux cent mille baril de
pétrole en production quotidiennement et
des centaines de milliers de tonnes de
co2 dans le bilan carbone du canada avec
nous en direct en studio ce soir le
ministre steven qui est bon pour soi
monsieur guilbeault parce que philippe
c'est une semaine assez intense n'est ce
pas je pense qu'on peut dire sur wii oui
effectivement je nous invite à aller
peut-être au-delà de baie du nord qui
est quand même une décision très
importante pour nous aider à comprendre
en 2030 parce que les objectifs sont en
2030 est ce que le canada va produire
plus ou moins de pétrole si on se fie
aux projections du régulateur fédéral
canadien la régie de l'énergie du canada
qui a produit environ six mois une étude
donc des projections de demandes et
offres de différents différents produits
energy de sécu la croissance de la
production pétrole devrait se poursuivre
jusqu'en 2032 et déclinée par la suite
souhaitant mon collègue le ministre des
ressources naturelles qui responsable de
ce régulateur le leur a demandé à la
régie de refaire leurs devoirs plus qu'à
son avis les scénarios proposés ne
tenait pas compte des efforts du canada
pour atteindre la carboneutralité en
2050 alors nous aurons dans au cours des
prochains mois c'est pas exactement
quand mais des nouveaux scénarios de de
la régie de l'énergie ce qui peut nous
amener à penser que la production
pétrolière va plafonner plutôt que 2030
de l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
nous dit qu'à l'échelle mondiale dont il
faut juste pour le clin d'oeil mais à
l'échelle mondiale la production devrait
plafonner autour de 2028 est ce que est
ce qu'on devrait pas aller plus
rapidement que cela pour atteindre les
cibles dont vous avez parlé un recul de
31% par rapport à 2005 les cibles de gaz
à effet de serre depuis de 40% par
rapport à maintenant pour atteindre les
6 de 2030 il faut réduire la production
de pétrole
pourquoi ajouter du pétrole il faut
retirer du pétrole de notre bilan mais
non nous l' approche que nous prenons
c'est de nous attaquer à la pollution
donc aux émissions de gaz à effet de
serre du secteur par un mélange de
karaté de bâton alors du côté bâton
évidemment la tarification carbone mais
une série de mesures réglementaires nous
avons déjà un règlement pour réduire les
émissions de méthane qui est un gaz à
effet de serre très puissants les
réduire de 40 à 45% d'ici 2025 et de les
réduire de 75% dans le secteur du
pétrole et du gaz d'ici 2030 alors ça ça
devrait permettre de faire de faire en
sorte que les émissions diminue
énormément dans ce secteur là mais il ya
d'autres mesures également réglementaire
qui s'en viennent notamment le plafond
pour les émissions mais est-ce qu'on
peut plafonner est-ce qu'on peut réduire
le méthane est ce qu'on peut faire tout
ce qu'on veut faire présentement pour
tenter de réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre tout en assistant à une
croissance de la production du pétrole
en même temps en alberta je pense que on
assiste probablement aux derniers
balbutiements de la croissance de la
production clairement mais le
gouvernement fédéral au plus d'emprise
là dessus puisque c'est d'une
juridiction provinciale
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
est largement de juridiction provinciale
où nous on peut agir c'est sûr c'est sur
la pollution mais effectivement si on en
croit les experts on approche du moment
où il n'y aura plus de croissance de la
production et on se dirige
progressivement vers un déclin
progressif de la production tant au
canada qu'à l'échelle internationale d
es ce que vous avez pas un rôle à jouer
en ajoutant pas de la croissance comme
vous le faites avec
lorsqu'on regarde les scénarios des
grandes agences que se soit l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie ou le giec
dans un cas comme dans l'autre on nous
on nous dit qu'on va passer d'un monde
où on produit à peu près 100 millions de
barils de pétrole par jour c'est là où
on est présentement à un monde où on
sera quelque part entre 25 millions et
35 millions de barils m par jour en 2050
alors il restera une demande pour pour
le pour les produits pétroliers qui
n'ose croire qu' on brûlera probablement
plus pétrole en 2050 on va l'utiliser
comme lubrifiant on va l'utiliser dans
différents procédés chimiques peut-être
encore du plastique l'asfac par exemple
mais le pétrole comme commodités comme
dans les transports dans le secteur
énergétique ce ne sera probablement plus
qu'à nous le canada va en produire
encore mais en fait nous produisons à
peu près un peu moins de cinq millions
de barils de pétrole par jour dans un
monde quand on a les chiffres juste des
mourides rit parce qu'on a justement
sorti les chiffres dans l'ouest canadien
4 millions quatre cent cinquante mille
mais le baril par jour dans l'est deux
cent cinquante mille barils par jour
donc mais un total de 4 millions 700
mille on est un gros producteur de
pétrole en 2030 en 2040 en 2050 le
canada sera toujours un gros producteur
de pétrole c'est une excellente question
mais je pense que dans un nous
produisons dont 4.7 millions de baril
dans un monde qui en a qui en produisent
100 millions est-ce que nous produirons
encore 4.7 millions dans un monde qu'il
n'en consommera plus que 25 à 35 je
pense que poser la question c'est un peu
et répond il est plus probable que notre
alors que partout ailleurs la production
décline au canada elle demeure stable ou
comme certains l'affirment clip qu'elle
va continuer de croître je pense
notamment à mon homologue albertain le
ministre exxon qui dit que lui de sky is
the limit il va toujours avoir votre
jour produire plus de pétrole au canada
je pense que c'est pas très réaliste
mais dans votre plan quand même sur le
climat vous dites que les entreprises
peuvent se transformer en producteur de
pétrole et de gaz parmi les plus propres
du monde donc on n'est pas en train
d'abandonner le pétrole ou de sortir du
pétrole on est en train de transformer
notre industrie mais on va continuer de
produire mais on verra ce poste un
gouvernement fédéral qui va décider est
ce que ce serait ce que ce qu'on va
continuer à ce que les compagnies vont
continuer d'investir là dedans c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup de marchés nous
en met en place des mesures pour que le
pétrole qui sue qui qui va être produit
au cours des prochaines décennies soit
le moins émetteur possible alors je ne
parle pas de pétrole berre où je parle
d'un pétrole avec la plus faible
empreinte carbone possible les deux
parmi les plus propres du monde de
pétrole propre mais d'un point de vue
gaz à effet de serre il faudra que le
pétrole qu'ils soient produits donc les
émissions soient les plus minimes
possible et ce qui reste comme
l'émission on devra le capturer le
séquestrer ou le compenser d'une façon
du nom pour être carboneutre ok je vous
emmène sur le câble caribou forestier la
protection du caribou forestier vous
demander au gouvernement du québec d'en
faire plus pour protéger l'habitat du
caribou ou est pour vous l' équilibre
entre la protection du caribou et son
territoire et la protection des emplois
forestiers juste une question qu'on doit
se poser dans tous les domaines
d'activité où il ya un impact sur
l'environnement ça veut dire à peu près
tous les domaines on part on vient de
parler du pétrole et du gaz on parle de
la foire est présentement on pourrait
parler d'autres domaines le secteur
minier et je suis d'accord qu'on doit
aussi trouver un équilibre mais
clairement nous ne sommes pas un point
d'équilibré au québec sur la question du
caribou forestier puisque les
populations sont en déclin et satan les
scientifiques du gouvernement du québec
du ministère de la faune que chute du
gouvernement fédéral ou les chercheurs
indépendants dans les universités arrive
à cette conclusion locle la preuve
la protection de l'habitat est
insuffisant présentement de façon à
protéger l'espèce qui périclite alors on
doit faire plus on n'est pas en
situation d'équilibré clairement et donc
en faire plus ça veut dire une
intervention de votre part ou la fin du
mois soit si le sait le plan b le plan a
dû joly dit depuis le début c'est que le
gouvernement du québec et nous puissions
arriver à une entente comme nous l'avons
fait avec l'alberta on a pu s'entendre
sur cette question là avec l'alberta on
est en négociation avec la colombie
britannique on est sur le point de
signer une entente avec le gouvernement
dog pound qu'on a négocié en l'espace
d'à peu près quatre mois alors si on est
capable de faire ça avec le gouvernement
d'orford je vois pas pourquoi on peut
pas le faire avec le gouvernement
françois legault il ya une commission
qui a été mise en place par le ministre
de la forêt pierre dufour et on parle
d'une stratégie au québec en 2023 est-ce
qu'on devrait pas attendre cette
stratégie pour nous pour la communauté
scientifique c'est beaucoup trop tard
on a besoin d'une entente rapidement au
pu le faire comme je viens de vous dire
on le fait avec d'autres provinces et
pas de raison qu'on doive en temps à
attendre encore un an et demi pour
mettre en place des mesures parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre que commencer une
négociation pour une nouvelle entente en
2023 ça ne s'est pas en place avant 2024
et il faut déployer les mesures et nous
on est prêt à investir avec le québec là
dessus des centaines de millions de
dollars or on dit au québec ne pas
ranger vos avec son on veut des normes
plus sévères on veut travailler avec eux
et on est prêt à investir avec eux
monsieur guilbeault merci c'est un
plaisir de vous accueillir en studio
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir ainsi avec vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit